If you read a text or hear something new,
your mind has a strong desire for order and
consistency.
Now, the moment your brain holds two contradicting
ideas, you experience distress.
Your mind often resolves this problem, by
tweaking the ideas until they become consistent
with the other stories you tell yourself to
be true.
Meat eaters for example who are confronted
with new information of how their dinner came
about can either eat less meat, deploy strategies
to cope with the new information, such as
denial, or do a little bit of both.
If two conflicting ideas are deeply ingrained
in our identity, the mental imbalance can
become overwhelming and intoxicate our thoughts
— and as a result we may believe even the
most absurd conspiracy theories.
To keep our sanity, it helps to learn about
this phenomenon, known as cognitive dissonance.
After a severe earthquake in India, rumors
circulated among people who felt the shock
but sustained no damage, about an even worse
disaster that was supposed to strike.
However, no disaster followed, and psychologists
began to wonder why such rumors sprang into
existence — it seemed counterintuitive that
people would share and believe fear-provoking
stories during such a difficult time.
Nearly 20 years passed before Leon Festinger,
a young psychologist, had a plausible theory
: The rumors were not “fear-provoking”
but instead "fear-justifying."
The argument: if we feel afraid and safe at
the same time, we invent explanations to reduce
such conflicting states of mind.
Festing called this mental imbalance “cognitive
dissonance”.
Cognitive dissonance is based on the idea
that when two ideas are psychologically not
consistent with each other, we change them
and make them consistent.
Festinger then examined whether a cognitive
dissonance can be strong enough to believe
in conspiracy theories even after they are
proven wrong.
To do so, two colleagues and Festinger, joined
a small apocalyptic cult led by Dorothy Martin,
a suburban housewife.
Martin claimed to receive messages from superior
beings from another planet called 'Clarion'.
The messages purportedly said that a flood
would destroy the world on December 21, 1954.
The psychologists observed that many members
quit their jobs and let go of their possessions
in preparation for the end of the world.
When the day came and passed peacefully, Martin
claimed that the world had been spared because
of the "force of good” that the members
had spread.
To cope with this situation and the heavy
cognitive dissonance it produced, the psychologists
hypothesized that the members had two options:
They could either change their situations,
and let go of the beliefs and actions that
formed the identity of their former self…
…or they could embrace new beliefs to stay
in the cult and protect the image they have
formed of themselves.
And that’s exactly what happened.
Some members faced the facts and left the
cult to regain their sanity, while others
believed Martin’s story to keep their threatened
worldview alive.
In their assessment, the psychologist concluded
that 3 conditions made it especially hard
for members to quit:
1.
If the members had deep convictions that were
relevant to their everyday routines.
2.
If they had done things that were difficult
to undo.
3.
If they received social support from other
believers.
Leon Festinger later wrote.“A man with a
conviction is a hard man to change.
Tell him you disagree and he turns away.
Show him facts and he questions your sources.
Appeal to logic and he fails to see your point.”
What are your thoughts?
Do you have an idea how we can change ours
and other people's minds?
If reason falls on deaf ears, can experience
maybe do the trick?
Share your thoughts and experience with cognitive
dissonance in the comments below!
This and all other Sprouts' videos are licensed
under the Creative Commons.
That means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms, online courses
or
to start projects - and today, thousands already
do!
To learn how it works and download this video
without Ads or background music, checkout
our website or read the description below.
If you want to support our mission and help
change education
visit our Patreon - that's patreon.com/sprouts.